avec nous ce soir l'isaf rue la
directrice générale de l'institut de
tourisme et d'hôtellerie du québec et
vincent guzzo directeur général des
cinémas guzzo bonsoir à vous deux
récents merci d'être avec nous lisent
aux fruits lorsque avance avec vous vous
êtes à la tête de cette institution et
thq qui forment les restaurateurs de
demain certains doivent se demander en
ce moment si ça vaut la peine encore
d'aller dans ce secteur avec toutes les
fermetures pour vous est-ce qu'il faut
accélérer la réouverture des restaurants
des bars des cinémas aller vers cette
plus rapidement possible moi je vais
vous dire le talent et restaurants ont
fermé le 30 décembre
comme descendre si le prix est pas
compliqué parce que tant qu'à faire on
aurait pu les fermer avant parce que le
30 décembre et commande était fait ainsi
les commandes qui sont très chers et
cuits les restaurateurs pays en tout la
maison aujourd'hui un code l'hôtellerie
mais l'hôtellerie c'est la même chose
d'aussi bon maintenant quand vous dites
est ce qu'on devrait ouvrir ou pas moi
si sûr que j'irai b oui il faudrait
ouvrir on est capable de maintenir le
maxi co2 on est capable de on est
habitués les restaurateurs sont
habituelles de suivre les règles
sanitaires mais d'un autre côté mon âge
mon autre chapeau obligé de dire que
quand notre système de santé est au bord
de l'effondrement et c'est un réel et
qu'un élève sur deux a besoin d'avoir du
seuil psychologique
mais je me dis est-ce que deux semaines
une semaine de plus de mesures
sanitaires si ça fait la différence
est ce qu'on peut attendre aux côtés
d'objets j'ai le car d'un côté pour
l'industrie oui oui vous trouverez mais
de l'eau parfois je me dis est ce qu'on
peut attendre c'est une catastrophe
je viens d'entendre d'oxford a pour 10 8
et
9 à 7 waouh moi je vais vous dire ou
alors qu en fait d'un tir in québec
d'avoir des lits d'hôpitaux c'est ça
oui ces mots les offrir vincent guzzo
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
pas que c'est moi je pense qu'on devrait
réouvrir les cinémas on devrait tout
rouvrir et faut se rappeler qu'une
partie de la dépression l'anxiété ou de
la santé mentale qu'on est en train de
souffrir si parce que justement on est
en train de nous enfermer qu'on
l'appelle de la prison ou pas c'est ça
que c'est maintenant le fait que notre
système hospitalier et au bar ouais
je suis pas en désaccord avec le fait
qu'on est au bas
la vraie question c'est faisons une
petite rétrospective à 15 ans ni sortie
de la première vague la deuxième vague
quand on a été qu'est ce que
j'appellerais un sens de normalité
qu'est ce qu'on a fait mais on s'est mis
à parler d'un tunnel de 6 à 10 milliards
on s'est mis à parler d'un ministre du
hockey du baseball et cetera on n'a pas
pensé à développer le plan là dans
l'éventualité où qu'il y avait une eau
la vraie question iphone la vraie
question monsieur guzzo et la vraie
question madame fruits là dans le fond
c'est de savoir est ce que les
restaurants et les cinémas contribuer à
alourdir les hospitalisations je suis
pas un expert de santé tandis que ce
programme est de dire mais aujourd'hui
en ontario ont dit on a un calendrier en
trois étapes voici on va les rouvrir on
pense que dans une situation semblable à
celle du québec on peut aller de l'avant
madame foudre est ce que le québec est
il monsieur guzzo et les restaurateurs
ne devrait pas avoir un plan comme ça un
calendrier
moi je veux dire au niveau de la
réouverture moi je pense que sincèrement
tout est bien là l'ironie de cendres
c'est un gouvernement de médecins avec
docteur couillard qui s'est occupé
d'économistes un gouvernement de
comptable et d'économistes qui s'occupe
d'une pandémie vraiment c'est l'ironie
de sa pensée paul que ce gouvernement là
qui est au gouvernement économique apple
ajoute de tout ouvrir alors oui les
hommes et d'un milieu de vingt ans dans
deux semaines dans une semaine on va
peut être ouvrir et je suis d'accord
pour dire qu'on nous alors indien soyez
soyons patients les offres là soyons
patients monsieur guzzo est ce que quand
tenue qu'on nettoie julich à la fin de
la vie mais au moins on est peut-être là
le replay quelques uns sont deux
semaines deux semaines ouais mais
monsieur vous savez avec elle quand on
est frais la confiance du public qui on
pousse le public à bout et le public
réagit
c'est le fun de dire c'est la faute du
public parce qu on oublie que le vin le
vin que septembre le premier ministre
nous a annoncé que la santé publique a
ordonné la fermeture des cinémas et des
restaurants et après on a dû avoir
monsieur harouna à l'assemblée nationale
au mois de décembre 20 veille à dire
j'ai jamais demandé la fermeture donc ça
voudrait dire que pendant trois mois on
sait faire répéter que c'était pas une
question d'économie c'est une question
de santé sur la santé publique puis
après la santé publique vient dire non
ce problème et donc faut se poser la
vraie question je vous dis pas qu'ils
font par mauvaise foi mais la vérité
c'est que si on engage un expert de
santé publique que monsieur roux doit
300 mille dollars par année
faut au moins il donnait le respect de
l'écouté et pas dix membres faire
changer d'idée puis on va fermer tout
seul alors je sais que je suis confiant
ça temps d'un instant je sens une
rupture de confiance à votre propos
monsieur guzzo est ce que est ce que
vous allez ouvrir vos cinémas même si
vous n'avez pas droit joue pas cette
question là monsieur guzzo parce que il
y en a qui veulent défier les règles en
ce moment est-ce que vous êtes prêts à
faire ça écoutez moi j'ai étudié en
droit donc je suis pas un de ceux qui
veulent contester
en ouvre en tout cas moi je suis un de
ceux là qui va contester une loi qui va
contester un décret qui va contester et
légalement cc c'est quelque chose qu'on
envisage si on le regarde mais à dire je
vais moi ouvrir les défier
c'est pas quelque chose qui m'intéresse
a à encore plus effritée
le respect que en ce gouvernement là
donc c'est pas mon rôle mais mon rôle
est quand même de dire qu'un à cestas et
les contradictions sont flagrantes vous
savez on parle d'un système de santé
fragile mais on s'est pas gênée au mois
de septembre octobre 2 menacé le milieu
de la santé que celui-ci faisait pas
vaccinés on les envoyait à la maison
centrale mise au fait la une pâtissière
au saguenay qui a décidé de rouvrir sa
salle à manger malgré l'interdiction
sanitaire
parce que des grandes chaînes de
restaurants qui sont sont ouverts en ce
moment où on peut aller chercher des
commandes de les policiers sont
intervenus
ce à un moment donné pour les
restaurateurs est ce que on a demandé
aux restaurateurs qui ont été fermés la
moitié du temps depuis deux ans
était là pour les restaurateurs ont
baissé d 1 extrêmement ici sinon
catastrophique 2 le prêt-à-manger dans
le tente on dirait un rendez-vous bay se
sont réinventés ils ont fait du
prêt-à-manger ils ont ils ont tous fait
le mouvement même l'hiver dernier
pourtant on va les encourager c'est long
mais l'actuel mal à l'allégeance à
raison légale morosité le à cause de
tout ce qui se passe sauf que je peux
pas approuver la désobéissance civile
parce que je trouve que ça donne rien ça
c'est déjà ce qu'ils sont vraiment à
court terme au cul moi ce que je demande
au gouvernement ses deux métiers de
maintenir l'ied le maintenir l'aide que
l'on avait pour pouvoir garder ses
employés pour pouvoir aider leur niveau
d des frais fixes maintenir l'aide et
ensuite en arriver avec un plat même je
retiens deux choses en terminale au riu
il faut rayon ouvrir pour vrai gérald il
faut pas aidé mais qu'est ce que nous
faisons et lisons nous lisons nous et du
son mach septembre que si on accepte
elle passe pas vaccinale c'était pour
pas nous le fermer et on nous a fermé et
comme moi j'ai appelé au mois de
novembre pour avoir de la clarté avant
d'ouvrir un autre cinéma l'on m'a dit a
pas de problème on ne fermera pas mais
on ne s'est pas gêné de nous fermer sa
justification encore une fois vers sans
goudron à la cour et tous les affreux la
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir un plaisir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne et r d